,
THERE ARE THANKS TO NICK PATON
WALSH.
OUR NEXT GUEST, JOHN RYAN BAUER
IS WORKING TO EASE THIS CRISIS.
HE IS A WORLD PROGRAM
CONTRADICTIVE HAITI.
HE JOINS ME NOW FROM THE
CAPITAL OF PORT-AU-PRINCE.
SEAN MARTIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I DO NOT HAVE TO TELL YOU WHAT
AN UPHILL BATTLE THIS IS FOR
YOU.
AS AMBITIOUS AS IT IS, I AM
JUST CURIOUS IS IT SOMETHING
NOT NEW TO THE COUNTRY, CRIME,
ECONOMIC ISSUES POVERTY
OBVIOUSLY, THE EARTHQUAKES, WHY
IS THE SITUATION SO DIRE THERE?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY
HAITI'S FACING CHRONIC FOOD
INSECURITY.
YOU MENTIONED THAT THIS IS A
VERY HAZARD PRONE ENVIRONMENT.
JUST THINK OF WHAT'S HAPPENED
OVER THE PAST DOZEN YEARS IN
HAITI.
YOU'VE HAD A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE
IN 2010.
FOLLOWED BY CHOLERA.
THERE'S ALSO HURRICANE MATTHEW
IN 2016.
THEN MAJOR EARTHQUAKE LAST YEAR
THAT KILLED 2000 PEOPLE.
IT DOESN'T STOP.
A LOT OF HAZARDS AFFECTING THIS
COUNTRY.
AGAIN, ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THEY'RE SO MUCH FOOD INSECURITY
IN THIS COUNTRY AND AS OF TODAY
WE BELIEVE IT'S AT LEAST 4.5
MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE FOOD
INSECURE ONE OF THE KEY REASONS
IS THE RECENT WEAKNESS OF
AGRICULTURE.
THIS COUNTRY IS NOT ABLE TO
FEED ITSELF.
IT USED TO BE ABLE TO FEED
ITSELF.
NOWADAYS, IT'S NOT ABLE TO FEED
IT DEPENDS ON IMPORTS FOR ABOUT
50% OF THE FOOD IT CONSUMES.
FOR SOME FOODS, THE DEPENDENCY
ON IMPORTS IS EVEN HIGHER.
80% OF ALL RICE CONSUMED IN
HAITI COMES FROM OVERSEAS.
THIS IS ONE OF THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THE CHOICES THAT WERE MADE
IN THE 1990S, WHEN THE HAITIAN
RICE TARIFF WAS BROUGHT DOWN
FROM 30% TO ALMOST ZERO.
THIS BANKRUPTED HAITI'S FARMERS
AND MADE THEM LESS COMPETITIVE.
OVERNIGHT, HAITI'S RIGHTS
PROTECTION HAS SUFFERED.
THE SAME IS TRUE FOR OTHER
CROPS.
HAITI'S PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN --
THEY HAVE EXISTED FOR A WHILE.
THEY PERSIST THIS YEAR.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING THIS YEAR,
IN ADDITION TO THE GANG
VIOLENCE YOU DESCRIBED.
THE IMPACT OF INTERNATIONAL
FACTORS ON THIS COUNTRY.
ESPECIALLY THE INCREASE IN FOOD
PRICES DUE TO THE WAR IN
UKRAINE.
>> THIS IT HAS JUST TURNED INTO
A VICIOUS CYCLE OVER THE PAST.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING YOU.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON, A
PROBLEM THAT'S EXISTED FOR
DECADES NOW.
I KNOW THE WFP IS ASKING FOR
SOME $39 MILLION IN ASSISTANCE
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS.
HOW DOES THAT FIT IN WITH SOME
REAL DIFFICULT QUESTIONS IN
DEBATES AS TO WHETHER FINANCIAL
SOLUTIONS ARE THE SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL WORK RIGHT NOW.
IN THE PAST, THERE HAVE BEEN
THOSE WHO SAID, DON'T SEND
MONEY.
THERE'S OTHER AID THAT CAN COME
BECAUSE OF CORRUPTION.
HOW DO PEOPLE WHO WANT TO HELP
KNOW THEIR MONEY, THAT IT'S
GOING TO HELP YOU TODAY, WILL
GO WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO?
>> AN INVESTMENT IN HAITI RIGHT
NOW IS --
IS AS IMPORTANT AS IT HAS EVER
BEEN.
BUT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO DO IS
SUPPORT THE POPULATION IN ITS
TIME OF NEED.
THIS MEANS PROVIDING
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE LIKE
FOOD, WATER, OTHER BASIC NEEDS,
TO THE POPULATION THAT'S
AFFECTED BY THE VIOLENCE WE SAW
IN YOUR VIDEOS.
THE OTHER FACTORS THAT ARE IN
PLAY.
WE CAN ALSO PROVIDE CASH
TRANSFERS TO BOOST THE LOCAL
ECONOMY AND MAKE SURE HAITIANS
THEMSELVES ARE ABLE TO PICK
THEMSELVES UP.
I HAVE TO SAY THE SYSTEMS THAT
ARE USED TO PROVIDE AID IN
HAITI TO PROVIDE A GOOD LEVEL
OF TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
THAT WORK HERE --
LOCAL NGOS, LOCAL CHARITIES, WE
WORK DIRECTLY WITH COMMUNITIES
TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE.
WE DO HAVE IMPACT.
WE NEED TO BE THERE AND
INCREASE WHAT WE DO TO MAKE
SURE HAITIANS GET THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED.
HAITI IS 4.5 MILLION PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACUTELY FOOD INSECURE.
1.3 IS A MINUTE EMERGENCY FOOD
INSECURITY.
THAT MEANS THEY NEED MORE
ASSISTANCE RIGHT NOW.
WE NEED TO STEP UP.
>> WHO ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG THE POPULATION THERE?
>> I THINK YOU'VE GOT TWO
GROUPS.
THERE ARE --
THE MOST VULNERABLE AREA IN
HAITI RIGHT NOW INCLUDES RURAL
AREAS AFFECTED BY DROUGHT, FOOD
PRICE INCREASES.
I'M THINKING OF PART OF THE
SOUTH AND ALSO PART OF THE
NORTHWEST, WHERE ALL THIS HAS
LEFT HIGH LEVELS OF FOOD
INSECURITY.
THERE'S ALSO THE POOR AREAS OF
PORT-AU-PRINCE.
A RECENT SURVEY SHOWED THAT ONE
OUT OF FIVE CHILDREN IN CIRQUE
DU SOLEIL IS ACUTELY
MALNOURISHED.
YOU SEE THOSE STATISTICS IN A
VERY SERIOUS EMERGENCY.
HAITI'S CHILDREN NEED TO BE A
PRIORITY.
>> TO SEE THESE NUMBERS AND
STATISTICS, GIVING ALL THE
CRISES WE ARE COVERING AROUND
THE WORLD, IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
HAVE PEOPLE LIKE YOU THERE ON
THE GROUND, ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU
HEAR THESE STATISTICS, FIGURES
ABOUT CHILDREN.
WE SAW IMAGES OF THEM AT
SCHOOL.
I BELIEVE 20% OF CHILDREN DON'T
EVEN ATTEND PRIMARY SCHOOL.
THIS IS AN URGENT MATTER THAT
WE ARE REALLY APPRECIATIVE THE
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE YOU ON THE
GROUND A